[Musik]
Schlagen Elvis war schwarz, es war weiß,
alles zusammen gemischt, direkte CD ist die
in Rolls Royce von Eva's Presley, unsere
Folie zum Buddhismus, Rolls Royce, jüdisches
Amerika, Fiat, Amia, die Moderatorin,
um zuerst Tausende zu werden. Ich denke, die Kings-
Regeln haben total jagannatham gelehrt
Elvis namens Edith Mutation Stuff unsere
Quotenanimatorin weit weniger 'mentale Tipps
Lager Amerikas eigener Stamm sogar verbessern
Nina Reiser sagte schräg die Endpumpe
Taiga begangene Gräueltaten spontan
desmos eine Flüssigkeit im amerikanischen Tom Green
Lantern er war die Stimme des Landes
und seiner Besten und Reichen  Überall berühmte Frauen
Ich meine, der Typ hatte alles
, woran du dich erinnerst, der großartige Chuck, tiefe Lüge,
direkter Rassist, ein Trottel, war einfach
und schlicht, gut, der verdammte Mann, John,
wie er meinen Kopf vermisst, französischer Akzent,
Geige, Amerika, um schamlos
staubig zu sein, bis 13 Kanonen drin  filme es stabil um
alpha chuck d danach dort bekannt zu
machen und das ein Givaudan und das ist
elvis hatte irische musik aus alten schwa
durch die wolke und hatte  Zahnschmelz zu beschädigen
und entsteht jetzt, da Asafoetida in der
Lage war, Sie könnten annehmen, dass Sokka ruhig ist
, das ist interessant, schöne Angst,
aber das ist alles jenseits von Amerikas
großartigen Dingen, Amerika tut großartige Dinge, Amerika hat
viel Schlechtes getan. Ich denke, der
amerikanische Traum war immer die
Fantasie von jemandem und jemand anderem  betrunkene
Sprachgemeinschaft Ich erfinde McAllister
und beendete zwei verschiedene Theaterstücke, die
prickelnd liefen, musste sich anschmiegsam fühlen,
Person, manchmal eine Hinterland-
Aston-Kultur oder der Ethan Hawke Alec
Baldwin, andere Migranten, die
nach dem Namen Coates Thailand ihr Herz
versteckten, als Strike Nine und dann Indian
Rolls  Royce-Fan beseemet versteckt über
Elvis nur von Amerika, es war es,
Sie wissen, hohl oder schräg das Haus,
dass es unser Film war, aus Angst, Ihre
Allergien, ein paar frühe Americana, die
in Christina versandt wurden, und ich kann im
Gig nicht jeden Mund und ihr Fell skripten  gangin
hi Dawa English this Esther miles oh it
was the I'm star and an event Viterbo
daughter  Bei einer Lippenberührung in Amerika werden wir den
zweiten Akt machen
und er sagte, ich erkenne es selbst als
destruktiv an,
wenn du Elvis ansiehst, ist irgendjemand bereit,
in einer Welt zu sein, in der alle zuschauen
, schau nicht zu, wie ich etwas tue